♪ HI, I'M JOAN AND
I CURRENTLY LIVE ALONE
IN A SMALL NICE HOME
NOBODY CALLS ME ON THE
TELEPHONE ♪
♪ SO, IT'S ME AND JUST ME
I USED TO LIVE WITH MY
BOYFRIEND STEVE
BUT STEVE CHOSE TO LEAVE ♪
♪ BECAUSE HE FOUND ME
BORING AND ADDITIONALLY HE
WAS CHEATING ON ME
BUT I'LL BE OKAY I ♪
♪ FOUND A NEW GUY I LIKE
BETTER ANYWAY
HE'S HOT, OH HE'S HOT
HE LIKES MY BODY AND MY
MY DOG IS MY BOYFRIEND
WE ARE IN LOVE
HE'S A 12-POUND CHIHUAHUA ♪
♪ I FOUND HIM ON THE
STREET AND I NAMED HIM DOUG
DOUG I LOVE YOU
I LOVE YOU BIG FAT NECK ♪
♪ DOUG IS MY NEW BOYFRIEND
DON'T WORRY WE
DON'T HAVE SEX
DOUG LIKES ROMANCE ♪
♪ ONCE I SHOWED HIM
PICTURES OF PARIS, FRANCE
DOUG, WE JUST KISS
WE TALK FOR HOURS ♪
♪ THEN I TAKE HIM
OUT TO PISS
WATCHES ME WHILE I
GET READY ♪
♪ THEN WE SHARE A BOWL OF
MEATBALLS AND SPAGHETTI
OH, DOUG, HOW I WISH
YOU COULD SPEAK ♪
♪ EVEN FOR A MOMENT JUST
TO MAKE A SQUEAK
I THINK I KNOW WHAT
YOU'D SAY BUT I LIKE TO ♪
♪ IMAGINE IT ANYWAY
JOAN I LOVE YOU
I LOVE THE WAY YOU
FEED ME HAM ♪
♪ YOU'RE MY LIFE, MY LOVE
MY EVERYTHING
I LOVE YOU JUST THE
WAY YOU AM ♪
♪ THE TASTE OF YOUR BATHROOM
GARBAGE SENDS ME
INTO OVERDRIVE
I'M TERRIFIED OF ♪
♪ VACUUMS BUT YOU'RE THE
MOST GORGEOUS WOMAN ALIVE
WE ARE IN LOVE
WE ARE IN LOVE ♪
♪ UNTIL OUR DYING DAY
YOU ARE SO COOL
AND SO FUNNY
IN EVERY SINGLE WAY ♪
♪ I GET TO STAR AS
WE KISS THE SKY AND
TOGETHER WE'LL
LIVE FOREVER ♪
♪ JOAN I HAVE TO GO BACK
NO, WHY
THEY SAID COULD I ONLY
BE A MAN FOR AN HOUR ♪
♪ BUT, WHO SAID THAT
GOD
I'M HIS FRIEND
FINE, IF THAT'S HOW ♪
♪ IT HAS TO BE
BUT WAIT BEFORE I GO
I HAVE TO TELL
YOU SOMETHING ♪
♪ ANYTHING
I ATE TWO OF YOUR SOCKS
AND THREE PAIRS OF YOUR
UNDERWEAR ♪
♪ IT'S CAUSED A BLOCKAGE
IN MY INTESTINES AND
IT WILL COST YOU $8,000
IT'S OKAY, DOUG ♪
♪ YOU'RE WORTH IT
DOUG I LOVE YOU
YOU LOVE ME TOO
THAT I KNOW ♪
♪ YOU'RE NOT JUST
MY BOYFRIEND
TO ME YOU'RE THE
BEST IN SHOW.
I LOVE YOU, DOUG